c'est un nouveau rappel à l'ordre pour
le ministère de l'intérieur qui se
trouve juste derrière moi il émane de la
cnil la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés
elle reproche au ministère de
l'intérieur d'avoir notamment utilisé
des drones pour veiller au respect des
mesures de confinement dans une décision
rendue le 14 janvier la cnil exhorte la
place beauvau à stopper l'utilisation de
ces engins équipés de caméras tant que
cette pratique n'est pas encadrée par un
texte de loi à ce jour aucun texte
n'autorise le ministère de l'intérieur à
recourir à des drones équipés de caméra
captant des images sur lesquelles les
personnes sont identifiables
de même alors qu'elle est obligatoire
aucune analyse d'impact n'a été
communiquée à la cnil concernant
l'utilisation de ces drones
le public n'était pas non plus informé
de l'utilisation des drones comme ils
auraient dû l'être
un texte est pourtant bel et bien dans
les tuyaux de l'exécutif vous en avez
certainement entendu parler puisqu'il a
mobilisé de nombreux manifestants depuis
le 17 novembre dernier
il s'agit de la loi sécurité globale et
de son article 22 adoptée en première
lecture par l'assemblée nationale fin
novembre cet article il détermine
justement le cadre d'utilisation de
drones par les autorités publiques
le nouvelle mobilisation contre ce texte
de loi sont prévues les 16 et 30 janvier
à l'initiative du collectif stop loi
sécurité globale des appels à manifester
auxquels se sont joints des
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme c'est le cas par exemple
d'amnesty international avec les membres
de la coordination stop loi sécurité
globale nous appelons à de nouvelles
marches des libertés partout en france
ce samedi 16 janvier 2021 nos libertés
sont en danger contre les violences
policières pour le droit à l'information
pour la liberté de manifester pour le
respect de notre vie privée pour nos
libertés
reprenons la marche enfin sachez que 20
nouvelle plainte contre x ont été
déposées par des manifestants
interpellés lors de la mobilisation du
12 décembre 2020 ces derniers des noms
des arrestations je cite arbitraire et
aléatoire ayant pour but d'entraver la
liberté de manifester des plaintes qui
s'ajoute à celle déposée le 7 janvier
contre x et contre le préfet de police
de paris par au moins huit manifestants
eux aussi interpellés le 12 décembre
ils dénoncent comme les hôtes des
entraves à la liberté de manifester